OK.
Welcome back.
Let's get right into audience questions, first
one.
David, if Biden gets elected in November,
what do progressive next?
So disclaimer, disclaimer, don't put the cart
before the horse.
Everybody's got to go vote.
There is no guarantee that Joe Biden is going
to get elected.
Republicans are certainly planning some October
surprises.
We don't even know what they are yet.
But certainly claiming victory over coronavirus
may be an emergency.
Use the vaccine, maybe more lies about economic
numbers.
Who even knows?
But do not put the cart before the horse.
Every single one of us needs to go out and
vote.
Here is the analogy I've been using to talk
about a possible Biden victory over Trump.
Biden winning doesn't score as many points.
Biden winning gives us the ball back.
We've been playing defense the entire time.
Trump has been president.
So if we get the ball back, that's when we
have to then put together our strategy for
how to put some points on the board.
Now, this reminds me of the importance of
getting control of the Senate and maintaining
control in the House because Joe Biden is
not the most progressive candidate, but he's
not likely to veto legislation that makes
it through the House and Senate.
Now, the devil is in the details there.
You might imagine something like Medicare
for all.
And you might say Biden would veto Medicare
He says he's not for it.
Well, Medicare for all is not going to pass
the Senate.
Right.
That's what you.
And this is not.
Don't attack the messenger.
Even many Democratic senators don't support
Medicare for all.
And if the Democrats get a majority in the
Senate, it would be a small one, maybe with
53 or 54 senators.
Medicare for all is not going to make it to
Joe Biden's desk.
So let's let's not let's think of, you know,
more realistic examples.
And Virginia is a very realistic example.
You've got a moderate Democratic governor
with a Democratic legislature and they've
gotten progressive things done.
And we've seen Virginia move to the left significantly,
even with a moderate Democratic governor.
But like I've said before, a Biden win is
the start.
So extend House control, hopefully take control
of the Senate.
And then in the immediate.
Joe Biden needs to be pressured to reverse
the insane Trump executive orders that have
accumulated while Donald Trump has been in
the Oval Office and then the House and Senate
need to go to work.
Biden is going to have to be pushed and he's
going to have to be pushed hard.
And what I've been trying to communicate for
some time now is even if Biden isn't as progressive
as Bernie and he's nowhere near as progressive
as Bernie Sanders, Biden is running on what
if he were elected president, would be the
most progressive platform that a sitting president
has had.
Just think through this, right.
Biden is accused by many of being barely a
centrist.
There's people say this guy's almost like
a moderate Republican.
If you look at Biden's tax plan the way I
did on Monday this week, it's well to the
left of Barack Obama's.
If you look at the things that are in Biden's
tax plan, abolishing the lower rate for capital
gains, dramatically expanding the Social Security
tax on people earning above four hundred thousand
dollars a year, eliminating the stepped up
basis, I mean, there's not even a what what
Joe Biden wants to do tax wise as well to
the left of Barack Obama.
If you look at Biden's health care plan, it's
obviously not Medicare for all, but it is
Obamacare.
Plus a bunch of stuff to the left of Obama,
including Biden has said he would be supportive
of lowering the age for Medicare and a bunch
of other things.
It is not Medicare for all.
But the point is, if Biden gets it done, what
he wants to do would be the left most position,
public option, etc..
It's about what Obama started from, which
is public option with more stuff like lowering
the Medicare age.
Biden supports the Green New Deal as a framework.
And that is something that I mean, Green New
Deal wasn't even a term back then.
So my point is not that Biden is the uber
progressive hero.
My point is Biden has already made it clear
that if he were president, his policy would
be the most progressive of anyone who has
been president, not who has run.
OK.
And he's got to be held to it.
And he has to be given the ability through
the House and Senate to actually get things
done.
And that's why if Biden gets elected, we've
gotten the ball back.
That's when the offense starts